a pec não pudesse gravar mas já sei que
vocês precisam vir porque vocês são
pessoas reservadas na época possam ver
uma pessoa bastante normal nós estarmos
com um bugueiro então os elétrons jogar
né ai eu já ouvi um barulho das janelas
ou perecer por cielo na porta
saiba que vamos jogar com muita calma se
cala a boca não quer saber ok pessoal
estratégia vai ser a mesma que é
basicamente não gostar ea pilha ou seja
não entregou esta quebra porque não vai
lá estar não é nem ipod choque janela
como funk godão parece que está
multiplicando meu para janela não estava
em produção e já tentou confundir as
coisas e até porta em porta da justiça
meu deus meu deus por que motivo ela
sou muito rápido aqui no quarto
ae
calma calma como tudo vai estar tudo bem
é e ficou tudo escuro já não parece
muito tempo que está passado foi de que
baixando moneo porque horas que se
seguiram assim são duas da manhã ainda
como é que é possível
ai meu deus ae
quem tem dois tem duas filhas duas
filhas na foto que aí está aqui
aí o filme sobre o cheiro
se é um instinto está dando certo ageu
hoje que tanto o discurso saído mais
cedo foi assim né porque sabe que a
janela toque pessoal vamos lá ver se eu
vou conseguir passar esta noite a
primeira série se eu conseguir passar
esta noite a primeira eu meto um dedo no
cu e cheiro meu seria o juro por deus
meu sabe que eu juro por deus que eu
faço isso se conseguir passar esta noite
sem morrer um único bem
ae é um mundo próprio steaua querem sair
mario roque tem uma pilha em uma pilha
vá lá eu tenho de aguentar este
campeonato é o fim
ai meu deus parece na porta e ela parece
muito rápido
olha o que ele fez isto tudo foi isto
que barulho aqui dentro na porta e
janela também está tudo bem aquém da
geral a 22 como eu sou dois só dois
podem dormir - vocês viram pessoalmente
prefiro ao mesmo tempo as altas porque
mente que balanços a identificação não
vou ficar sem luz
eu vou ficar sem luz a janela eu vou
ficar se fala em uso
já no sector já mencionei que eu tô
escuro tudo escuro são porta tudo
gostoso porque há muita pilha vontade e
muita pilha dark que tanto o prédio
ficou 50 pilha da área que aguentam foi
empilha frame a frame
ai meu deus eu ficasse biel som ficasse
pirão rodrigo fui lá falar 5 ai-5 falava
em que vivia por favor deus em pilha aa
justo mandar o filho da [ __ ] am
ai meu deus eu consegui
eu consegui sair por aí né knight a uma
noite 7 o vídeo vai ficar por aqui mas
deixem só confirmar se existe uma noite
exceto os do google
ao ir a pé para que não então é isso a
lógica porque com isto está fazendo no
estado e nós conseguimos comprovar é
seis noites sobretudo à noite 7 plena
noite de halloween no não sei se vou
jogar esta noite se quiserem um jogo mas
o que interessa é que nós conseguimos
passar os três noites a um jogo completo
e é isso pessoal quanto com a flec
favorito fiquem bem e até a próxima